josh rogers pitched against them with
the orioles june 14th of 19 gave up
two runs and four to third
swing gonna miss on a diving breaking
ball
connor schwarber former national
returning to washington bringing
boy you think he had played there 10
years but that's how good he was for
them this year 25 home runs and really
half a season
and this has popped up a mile high right
side
it's josh bell's play
and so the youngster ruiz will get out
of the way two down
[Applause]
he gets jammed fly ball to left andrew
stevenson has it and josh rogers walks
him in but gets three pretty routine
outs
eduardo rodriguez he arrayed just under
five well eddie needs a big one tonight
that's an understatement
and that ball is hit hard into the left
field corner
name digging for two
that's his 23rd extra base hit as
annette
and his 14th washington double
look what he said look at the target
set up in the dugout
walk number 141
bell to right jd martinez
back to tag lane thomas and martinez
will launch one
and with the ball cut off both runners
are safe
bogarts cut it off and soto followed
thomas and juan soto continues to
develop as a very good base runner
ground ball up the middle it's kiki on
oh low throw dug out by galbrak
able to get out of the inning though and
keep those runners at bay
that's
going to be called a fair ball
escobar says it was picked up in the box
there is part of the box that is in fair
territory
and that's what james hoy is pointing
out to alcita's escobar
just a little diagonal part of that box
is in fair territory
that ball is hammered out to center
thomas back to get it
and with a runner approaching second
base denver's
just trotting back to first
ball eight
day
couldn't walk 10 times this weekend
swinging a ground ball right side base
hit
soto rounding second will not challenge
martinez who gets to it quickly and
throws it in on two hops to third
and to base hit up the middle soto had
to make sure it got through so he was
retreating as he should
and they're loaded with nobody out for
jordy mercy
got him he struck him out not an
overpowering pitch but he fanned it here
comes one two
and popped up
and a play off first base here's dalbeck
to make the play and the runners are
going to stay
at first second and third and two down
low ground ball softly hit he can really
run the flat
and got him at first base
got him
stevenson out kk with the play of the
knights
with the bases loaded and the red sox
escape
what a play
it got past eddie and once it did you
thought no chance to make a play [ __ ]
dove bare-handed and just like a hot
potato flipped it to first dulbeck
stretched and picked it out and that's
how the red sox get out of the bases
loaded jam in the fourth you talk about
the situation the scenario and what's at
stake here this play
has wild card ramifications big time
this late in the season
there you go gonna drop and go to second
for a force the pitcher didn't run and
the nats turn it into a double play
and if josh rogers just looked back at
ruiz and pumped his fist
i think kate bear let him know what was
going on there and played quarterback on
that thing that's what happened i'm out
i'm out look at he's standing right
there and now you're a double play
now you are a stone double play
and that is a beautiful thing for the
pitcher and he knows it he's psyched the
two down the 3-2 coming
and he struck him out
he sets him down
one man left nothing nothing game
diddy looking to do damage right here
the pitch swinging a shot into left
field that's a base hit bogarts will
have to hold at second as it quickly got
to stevenson here we go the red sox for
the first time in the game have a runner
at second base
it's first and second with one down for
hunter renfro
swinging a high fly ball that one's deep
back
[Applause]
a three run homer and the red sox break
out they lead three to nothing we were
waiting so patiently here's dalbeck and
he drives one high and deep into left
field back on it stevenson stevenson at
the track at the wall and it is gone
back to back for the red sox and they
lead four to nothing we've been waiting
for this offense for have we ever they
needed that back to back they are
feeling good the big boppers came
through
it's brazier now in he comes into a big
big spot now with two on and none out
fastball to short trying to move the
runner up the throw is going to get him
on the first play
look at that he did he struck him out
[Applause]
oh two
swing and a miss he struck him out of
slider and brazier
screams at the top of his lungs in
celebration on the mound what a spot for
brazier and the sox stay ahead for
nothing
that's well hit to left stevenson back
oh he's got it
closing speed going on to the track
[Applause]
that is a long ball the opposite way
stevenson twisting turning and makes
another great play
but look at the adjustment andrew
stevenson makes her with his back to the
play he flips around gets his head up
and his head around that's the key to
that play
and escobar goes big fly to left
see
you
later and then answer on the board
on escobar's fourth of the year
pull through for
[Music]
[Applause]
look at the throw by j.d look at this
and the tag by devers the tag made the
play he throws inside and he goes out
there and gets him
he is out no
line to left
oh
stevenson again
third base empire says it's a clean
catch
[Applause]
and he hung that one jordy mercer to
left still going
see
you
later
a couple of solos and the nats are back
in it
missed his spot he walked in on the man
back to back walks with two down
and it's not the tying runs are on base
for washington
[Applause]
ah
pop up into right field that should do
it renfro is there
and the red sox win it they had to have
it
and they pull it out tonight that's 90
victories for the red sox
13th time since 02
winning at least 90 games none bigger
all season
you